HAIEISSSIBLY MOF
THCOD- CONTAIN M.E GENETIC CHANI
IM KNOE THDY
ASVERED IN SOUTH
CA BUT UNCLEAR WRE
THE STRAIN DOEPEARG  SOUTH
INO FOUNDIN BAN D BELGIUUTH AF.
E UK
AND SE B AFRICANOTHEOUNTRISUIT L
E  SURE,
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE NEVARKS.CA
LOWER.
THHETHE , LO A PER T AIS COVID-
THAT'S WHYE TO PIC
IT UTHR SEQUENCING WHAT THE S AR
IS
STILL QUITE NEW,Y
ABT
FEW DAYS, SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE T
GUIDE US A HIS
G CTION, IE
SEVERE, IST ESCAPING VE ALL UNAD
THE T IS THAT WE CAN
MAKE SOM BASED
ON THE.ARE S IN THIT IS
THAT IT HAS MUTATIONN WITH T OT
VARIANTS OF CONCERN.
LOOKING AT THI
IT HAS MANY MURE
THAN WE'VEIN THE OTHER
UR VARIANTS OF CONCERN.
SO WE OTHEITEWUT
VERUT.
SO OVER 30 M Y IS GOINA BIUSO F
UNDERSTANDVE TO
>>'M WORRIEDWAIMS R STUDIES STG
VNTE
THIS, NOT ONLYS IT HAVARACTER VL
URE WHETHER ITULU 'T
KNOW, THTIBODIES AND THOSE
E STUDIES WE STILL NEED TO
WHAT M  THAE'S A
LIKELIHOOD IT WILL HAVE SO
IMMUN.T DOES, THEN W
BECAUSE THVACCINES PROTECT TRT
OF CONCE B A PONSE. THVA
INFECTIONS, EX M YOU K V
THEM TT E ARNS.
YOE TONI OF
TH A IT WILL BYPASVACCINES
HOY COULD WEEKS CATESTS TAKE A ?
AFRICAN CONTT  NEXT
VARIANT, BY THE TIMEAVE
FIED IT -- IN OTHER WO INFECTE
SICK, HAD A TEST, YOU DID THQUE
TWEKS OR SO, KNOW, ONETO TWO, MB
AFTER E  STARTE
F THE VARIANT.
MANY WAYE G WITHHIVIRUHAT WEEA
THAT TIS OUR SID
WITHIN A WEEKSATN , AND SOT
IS Q I THA
EFFORTS BEING MADE IN SOUTH
RIY TO CONTA
D TO IDENTIFY, K
KNOW,
REALLYEEN PUT INTOLY FOCUS THA
BEFAIL IDOINLIKELY TT THIS
EAD QUITE DELY. E  FR
VEOUE SOUTH AFGORNS TEMENT SAYI'
PEOPLETINGCOUNTRIES TH HAV
IS
INACVER TH O
THIS PWE HE RV
IMNG BANS  FROTRS A NEW
ED UL O
D
SPREAD, DO YOUENT?
>> AGREE WITH IT, AND I THINK
IS W
YOU ARE ALIN A PANDEMIC,
ESPECIALLY ONE THAT SPRE RAPIDLO
RY TBADOWNESOW, SHUN
THE REST O WE'RE NOT
S
UNFORTUNATE, THIS  THAT HAS
BEEN TAKEN.
HAVEOPEDE ULD WA WIT
PUT IN THE VIRUSHAS TO BHE
ING WITHHIS
AT A GLOBAT THIS WEE 100 INS
RIN AFRICA FROM TH
THH THCOVAX SCHEME.
TALKED ASHOW, YOU ANI HAVE TALK
W.H.O. HAS SIMPLY MORAL THAT TH
SUE SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF
OF E PORLTOTHIS
CONCERNS ABOUTHE
COENT HAVE THELS AT ITS
>> WHAVE SOMOLS,E
E QUITNASCENT, BUT
WERE MISSI OTHERS.
OUHIBOT A IS ABOUT
REST OF THE WORL TERMSF
ACCESSO VACCINES -- WE HAVE
EEN LARGMBOFVACC BN TH
COINE N N'VAQUISITION TAM D THRA
KSD NO
THE BIG CHALLENGE OFOU KNOW, VII
MAE AFRICAIES
LACK THA.
SO WE G WAIS
IMPORTISNNOT WS NN D THIS AS EUF
IT DOESN'TELP THAT  COUES HAVE D
VACCINES, AND THEN JUST WHEN
THEY'RE ABOUT TO EXPIRTHFRICA.
SO, YOU KNOWOF USE
VE T USI
TH,  EXPIRING.
WE HAVE TO FY ATS L OF US MUSTOG
WE HAVE